i think it really is just like a
pandemic world thing um i used to
make a lot of videos going out and going
to tokyo yeah with joey like doing a
bunch of things and with like my friends
in tokyo
and i don't like i think streaming from
or not streaming i don't like shooting
from my house because a
i don't want to accidentally like reveal
where i am
exactly like i'm in the you know i'm in
the countryside so
it's a little bit hard to figure out
where i am but like just in case it's a
little bit freaky and
you know you're like i guess like your
inspiration is kind of limited when
you're just doing it from home by
yourself
yeah someone got very close to finding
my where i live right now oh
how did i tell you this no so like there
was like a bar code that was like
roughly like shown for like a second in
one of my videos from one of the
packages i opened right
right and they went around like texting
people being like i know where conor
lives
and then so and then what happened was
that even though this this barcode was
barely visible
somehow you barely it's in the
background and somehow it's scanned
when you put that like when you put the
scanner to it that's what you meant i
didn't understand yeah yeah yeah
so so like when you because when you get
a japanese package there's i think any
package there's always a barcode on it
yeah
and this was like in the background of
the shot and someone somehow
scanned it i have no idea how they got
it like the fidelity behind them
yeah i have no idea i was thinking
because they literally did the
enhancement
because i found where where it was and i
was like there it didn't even work when
i was doing it
so i don't understand how they managed
to pull it off because then they were
going around sending me a screenshot you
know like i know you live connor
and then uh so i looked at the thing and
luckily japan post only
told my postcode which is still not good
but i was like all right
it's only a postcode i'm like yeah i was
like close though
yeah i was like all right what are you
gonna do come to this giant ass place
with all these like
ten-story apartments yeah i'm like what
are you gonna do we can do find my
apartment i'm like i would i would
gamble even if you found
a building i lived in i'm like i'd still
feel safe honestly yeah i'm like try and
find the door don't try and find the
lawsuit
but well but like i mean you know i was
it was very concerning
so be careful with barcodes yeah yeah i
had no idea that was a thing so
now [ __ ] that person going around being
like this is so cool i have connor's
address
but it's whatever i mean i was like all
right cool you're loose
why would you see a barcode in the video
thing i'm going to scan that i'm going
to [ __ ] try and scan that i love you
that's why i love him so much i must
find out where he lives
i mustn't talk to him that's how much i
love him yeah i probably have
cockroaches in my apartment why would
you want to find out where i live i
don't know
because he loves you and your cochlear
implant everything about you
all of you it's so [ __ ] creepy
yeah it was but yeah but i mean where
you live there it's
probably really safe though it is except
we just had a stabbing
first one in a hundred years or it never
happened so it freaked everybody out
was this was this like national news um
it was definitely
like um it was like she's okay yeah
she's like professional
oh [ __ ] i thought that's actually news
yeah and um
and it makes no sense but then a whole
week later he didn't get caught and
everybody forgot so there's that wow
okay
but um but that's a misnomer that's not
a good representation of
my like hometown it's very lovely and
quaint and wonderful feels like they
were
where i grew up there i remember when
someone died when i was like 18 they're
like yes the first death
in this area in like 25 years like
murder jesus
it's a big deal when it normally doesn't
happen yeah in like tiny towns yeah
that's the thing with like
especially like japan right it's like
there's either no crime
or like [ __ ] [ __ ] like world war
three yeah yes
that's it's definitely there's no like
medium anymore yeah but i'm also
you know i lived in l.a for like eight
years where there was a shot everywhere
like i remember the first like someone
got stabbed it's never happened in l.a
i remember the first time i went to la
it was the first anime expo i went to
and uh i remember like first morning i
woke up
in the hotel right and it's one of those
like radio clocks
so like the alarm goes off right and
then the radio starts playing right
being like you know it's
the alarm yeah as the alarm right and i
was and i thought that was really cool
because like i'd only ever seen that in
movies
oh my so cause like you know i was like
okay you know what like this is a
feature
i'm just gonna do it for this one
morning and see if it's like you know
cool or anything like
you know because i don't know i never
had anything like that in australia
right or japan
so i was like this this might be cool so
like alarm goes off at like 8 am or
something radio starts up or this is
like it's a beautiful morning here in
los angeles last night we had
three shootings happening down in the
downtown area
but it's a lovely summer day today have
a good one everyone i was like
all right i don't want to go outside
right now mine the helicopters finding
the suspects
yeah exactly yeah that happened that's a
real thing yeah there's always a
helicopter
shining like spotlights down everywhere
at all times yeah
it's pretty just trying to go to like
7-eleven your own personal spotlight
you don't do that where it all happens
[Music]
and nobody goes to class on friday